they reject nation it's Greg Alva here
Wow I'm seeing you so often lately man a
few days ago John and I did a video
covering that makeup test footage from
Joaquin Phoenix as the Joker had a lot
of thoughts had a lot of opinions and
somehow I miss this entirely this has
been out for a few days here it's some
actual footage of Joaquin Phoenix moving
around on set in the Joker makeup
haven't seen it yet only 30 seconds long
but at this moment I want any little bit
of I hope this movie has that kind of
yeah please
hey real quick I want to say thank you
to everyone who's been joining our
patreon page over there we do awesome TV
show reactions for many a shows
including Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood attack on Titan and my hero
academia Gotham Riverdale and
supernatural as well as weekly Q&A s
Stacey's here with me right now because
she has an upcoming event going I
watched um about that Stacey
I sure do so Star Trek fans Trekkies get
ready October 5th we are screening Star
Trek to the Wrath of Khan at the multi
bond theater that's right on the roof of
Ricardo Montalban Khan himself Theatre
in Hollywood doors open at 6:30 you can
enjoy some drinks like Romulan ale
dressed up in costumes take fun photos
we're in prizes that trivia have a Q&A
with Scott mance and one of the
producers of Star Trek to the Wrath of
Khan and the film starts at 8:00 tickets
only twenty bucks you can get them at
arena scream comm there's also gonna be
a bunch of really familiar faces there I
think you guys are coming I might show
up Dan were coming mara canopic Scott
mance Robert a real tree
Ashley V Robinson John Roca all the best
people are gonna be there they're coming
because I asked them to their good
friend it's gonna be a night for fans so
I hope everyone joins a kind of cell
yeah I sure [ __ ] do well let's watch
this video linked in the description box
for that event people
favorite chef always calamus
there is perfect thank you
[Music]
Oh what this movies so bad 17th ledger
Raskob yeah he is he he's he's ledger in
his face but he is what's the original
guys names Cesar Romero Romero Osby
Cesar Millan Cesar Romero in his like
suit yeah everything it kind of looks
like a classic clown mixed with a
classic Joker a little yeah like classic
Joker from you know the early days of
like you're saying Cesar Romero you know
like long hair like the Heath Ledger but
also with a classic clown makeup but his
walk is the most different it's like
even though I feel like out of the
Joker's they've got him the one this
reminds me most of is Heath Ledger Heath
Ledger's walk was always hunched over
his walk if you look at it man he's just
like he's like I don't know if you
notice this moment back here but there's
like someone getting their ass kicked in
them in the background
why would I yeah that's true that's how
she is in real life
helps just always look out for yourself
that's right I don't see nothing
blinders blinders on I've given a lot of
thoughts on what I think about Joaquin
Phoenix you guys can go watch that video
Ivey I don't want to just keep repeating
myself but Stacy no one's really heard
what your thoughts are on anything
that's coming out with this walking
Phoenix like so please tell us your
thoughts the only thing I've tweeted is
that his makeup looks like when that
direct deposit hits and I go straight to
Sephora for that sale I really like this
look
Joaquin Phoenix is one of those actors
where am i I'm always interested in what
he's doing does it matter if it's like a
romantic comedy leave his dramatic roles
he always brings something scary but
interesting compelling to the table so I
mean he's really in in the handful of
actors that could portray the Joker in a
way that the fans would like it he is
like one of the only ones in there I
find this so fascinating what's been
going on with this movie because when
this movie was announced a lot of people
were like what the hell why why why are
we doing this movie that sounds strange
no we're gonna have the Jared Leto one
yeah and then over time as more news has
been coming out more and more people
have been getting
excited yeah for this egg oh wait
walking Phoenix is a pretty amazing
actor after all and then they see the
test footage there you get the tone you
get a tease if a lot of people are
talking about this makeup and I've seen
a lot of people complaining and we do
touch on the other video that this is
like the Joker origin so I'm figuring
out what do you have to be it's subject
to change from what I've seen I feel
like there's something's gonna happen
where the inspiration of clowns just
clicks is they had that one picture
where he's talking with the big clown
guy he seems really fascinated to buy
him this has to just be like the early
stages of it and it's kind of cool to
watch it develop over time and I'm
wondering if in this moment if he
already has risen to some kind of
chaotic power in the crime world it's
got all these other people around who
are in clown makeup and stuff yeah maybe
it's like a parades going on you you
really don't know what these scenes are
or what they're gonna become you just
see a little bit of that taste of the
chaos gonna bring which is great I love
it they picked this era what is this
supposed to be like the 70s 1940s at
night I am watching the deuce on HBO the
culture I love the clothes I'm loving
the way that New York City in itself is
this character and constantly changing
to take that decade that I've become now
a little bit obsessed with and then
let's put this iconic origin character
and you know actors and director and
let's all mix it up and that's and
that's what I'm the most excited about
is to see the Joker in like I know
what's funny I haven't really yeah I
don't remember if it's like the 70s or
80s you guys can comment below and then
you know hate on us or just be kind of
tell us we're asking you leave with that
either way I haven't really even that
fixated on it but you bring up a good
point with that because it would be
really fascinating to see an exploration
of a guy's character origin and how much
the environment and the time affects who
he becomes in that moment yeah
the Dark Knight I mean that takes place
in the 2000s with all kinds of like you
know cyber technology and that is a part
of the film right you know and it
effects the plot so to have it be in
this era pre-internet pre cellphones pre
everything they social media everything
that kind of makes up or effects in our
society today ready to see that with
this kind of character also
you brought the Dark Knight of course
and it seems very dark night I didn't
even think about it so right now he has
the mask he dad and at the beginning of
the Dark Knight he's wearing a clown
mask wait he's a dirty what did the
clown's head I think one of them does
but he just has ears
this one right here though it's very
dark night ish to do the expression have
the Joker makeup on but also do a clown
mask over that I just like the word just
gotta fixate on that and from here on
you know behind like this is very
clearly an extra that kept their phone
you know and was filming it you know and
I'm like no don't do that let's keep it
special keep it secret yeah this movie
doesn't come out like 2019 or something
but what's also really interesting to me
is remember when there was like Jared
Leto footage being revealed like similar
on set stuff in the photos
there's nothing but hate yeah this time
it's like ruins it so excited I feel
like you know even if people want to
pick on it a little bit that's really
not like the focus of the conversation
the focus has been like overwhelmingly
passed
it's funny how we're getting such little
reveals of him one at a time I find it
very fascinating cuz the first one was a
photo of just him as Arthur which I
learned today and I'm so late to this
his name's as full names Arthur Fleck
and Jason Dolan actually messaged me and
said like did you get the Ben Affleck
thing I'm like what a flick like so
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah please just carry around a duck the
whole time just like petted like it
that'd be great that'd be so jump on
like weird shtick yes his weird spent be
such a [ __ ] phoenix character choice
that he made like hey Todd I'm gonna
have a duck the whole time and a Pettit
and yeah the Ducks name is Ben I
remember before okay first you get the
photos of just him as Arthur and then
you get the test reveal which kind of
hints at a tone and also shows the
makeup and then you get here where you
were watching the body language and now
we're probably gonna get something we're
like ooh never get here his voice
that's like that big thing and I've kind
of been opting for this the first deep
voice Joker
I suppose I'm going to have to teach you
a lesson so you can better follow in his
footsteps
and I feel like Joaquin Phoenix could
pull off an amazing deep voice Joker
really I don't know hide him use his
deep voice before you ever seen you were
never really here or I haven't seen that
yet but I did just watch her and he's
very like soft and innocent voice
sounding in that that's true either way
I'm like that's like the next reveal
right like just worried sound like oh
yeah talking to like a clown or
something maybe he's talking to the
clown as Arthur that'd be great to hear
him speak it's the first time but it's
not in the Joker character it says
Arthur black right that's what I'm
wondering is his voice gonna change it
when he's Arthur and then when he
becomes the Joker will it really evolved
I don't know either way I'm excited I'm
so curious about everything how does his
like first kill come out like I'm very
first I'm curious about a comic-book
characters origin like really happy yeah
well there's so much creative freedom
here yeah all right guys well how much
is this footage excite you comments
below you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
about porfavor
if you're in the LA area or if you're
playing visiting LA on October 5th and
we're planning on skipping venom that
way you can make sure to go to this
awesome Star Trek event band at the
Montalban theatre yes
October 5th doors open in 30 movie
starts at 8 tickets at arena screen calm